[拍手]
いやー楚軍元気稼働は子の名前は
archi どあー木ノ葉加瀬じゃあポケットモンスター
縮めておけばこの世界にはどう呼ばれて居る生き物がたくさん住んでおるちゃうードゥ
特には州の好きなポケモンがおってなゴローニャという名前だったかな
ローナっていうポケモンがわしの ok にいるのぽようなんじゃがー
ポケモンには不思議がいっぱい世の中にはバカだポケモンを持ってなあこの子ローねっ
というポケモンは大爆発という技を覚えるのじゃあ名前の通り自分が大爆死そのまま
行ってしまうのジャガー
足 archi ド派手実際に大爆発をしたゴールにはこの目で見た事が無いのじゃよ
なので今回はは強いが直接ゴローニャを作りダイナマイトを使って実際に五郎にあって
大爆発した後どうなっているのか見てみたいと思うんじゃなぁ
どれだけ酷いんじゃのかを疑問が自ら大爆発するその後どんな姿になっておるのか非常
に興味深い緊急なのじゃあ延期にごろ寝をつくっていくんじゃぞ
アピッピカチュウさあ必要なものじゃまずは石井は定期料準備するんじゃなゴローンで
見つけるじゃぞ後発泡白でこれは頃に本体じゃん
を決めちゃんそう版ゴールできれば手足を作るんじゃんあとすごい自分が家具
ランドリースタッフもたくさん準備するんじゃその後爆薬をつける人も準備するんじゃ
なぁ
行ったらします混ぜあとは各自担当を決めていろんなものを作っていう文じゃあなーて
足を付けるもの顔を作るもの
発泡スチロールに石をつければの様々じゃあがこれだけを人数でもかなりの時間が
かかりそうなんじゃなぁ
[音楽]
ん
2ん
[音楽]
ん
goo
たい時にゴローニャの顔が完成しましたそうでしょう
割とゴローニャっぽく見えると思うんですよつけたらちゃんとそれっぽくなるとこれ
どっから見てどう完全にいい
銀行まずコーンやっぽくなっているもうして簡単です頑張ってついて過剰
ああああああ
me
goo
yeah
bejean
re ほっ
ai
me
ほっほっほというわけで早速五郎者の感性じゃ
制作時間は大人15人で約4時間じゃ
頬ををゴローニャできてばっかりで非常に心苦しいん者が遊ぶ大爆発して記述して
もらうんじゃあそういわ山だけ大爆発していくんじゃなーこーいっぱいというわけで頃
にゃの台場ガーゼの準備が整ったわけですかなぁあらすぐ風呂に by 爆発して
もらおうと大村では五郎ニャー
台場数スパイクんじゃな
32位英智どりゃー平が税
[音楽]
car
ええええええ
[音楽]
ああああああ
誰がっ
ダガー
花がー現金の次の大きなさーん
[音楽]
me
teame
あっはぁ
おっ皆さんすいませんのショッキングな映像だったの
ジャガー工芸品とはこれでも大丈夫なんじゃなぁ
あのボローニャもっぽい品センターに行くと一発で元通りちゃう
[音楽]
どうやって戻るんじゃのうウィンナーをポケモンゲットじゃぞ